في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في ان خمسه اشخاص
اصيبوا في قصف اوكراني استهدف المدينه
خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه واضافت السلطات
المحليه ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت
المدينه نحو 49 مره وتسبب القصف بتضرر
عشرات المنازل السكنيه
وفي بخما قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
القتال من اجل المدينه مستمر وان الروسا
حاولوا استعاده اراض فقد السيطره عليها
امس لكنهم فشلوا واضافت الهيئه ان اكثر من
30 اشتباكا جرى امس على محاورت ومارينكا
ينفذ لواء الهجوم الثالث الاوكراني عمليات
في باخموت تهدف عملياتنا الى استعاده
وتحسين المواقع في منطقه مسؤوليتنا وبشكل
عام على طول خط ضخمه العدو اصبح ضعيفا
الان ومن هكا فهو لا يملك القوات التي كان
يملكها في فبراير من هذا العام نحاول ان
ناخذ مواقع مفيده لنا ونعمل على تدمير
مشاه العدو بالاشتراك مع وحدات اليه
وانواعا حديثه من المسيرات